all right joining me now Molly Hemingway
editor-in chief of the Federalist Fox
News contributor Byron York Washington
examiner correspondent Mark Lavine
former Democrat member of the Virginia
House of delegates um Mark uh Joe Biden
I don't think is going anywhere but can
you deny that there is momentum building
to push him out because they see the
numbers that the New York Times is
reporting ABC News is reporting Sienna
pretty much every poll out there and it
is a nightmare for Biden Democrats often
get worried about all kinds of things
but uh every Democrat I know firmly
supports Joe Biden I I think they
understand that he has the Integrity to
be president he has the Integrity yes he
does I mean Donald Trump today testified
about how he and all his kids were
committing fraud we're talking about
we're talking about Biden this is the
guy that you say has the Integrity to be
president I tell where is he ever
demonstrated Integrity on what on What
form inter invoking his family's tragedy
to actually to actually like you know
empathize with someone from a huge
National disaster Laura look on the
international stage Harry Truman Ronald
Reagan Joe Biden no one has stood up
democracy and Ukraine and Israel more
than Joe bid ukra everyone knows Ukraine
has lost Molly the the foreign policy
angle here is not to be understated even
you know even the New York Times they're
reporting on Ukraine even the head of
the defense Ministry if Ukraine
basically said we're at a stalemate well
and it's worth remembering that when
Trump was President the media and before
he was president the media said if he
were elected president we would have
nuclear war breakout there would be a
destabilization across the world and
instead what you had was a very strong
National interest based foreign policy
we went after our enemies but we didn't
get embroiled in various conflicts when
President Biden took office he said
America is back baby and he said he
would assert this
verys mature foreign policy we have had
nothing but disaster globally the world
is on fire there are we had a stable
situation in the Middle East he decided
to prioritize Palestinian interests to
help Iran become a dominant uh become
dominant again in the region and we see
how that's going you have the Ukraine
war which has devolved into a stalemate
you have China continuing to rise that
has actually been one of the worst
problems for his presidency and that's
just one of the problems for the Biden
presidency and Byron what's Wild here is
that Biden really is doing his best I
think to put a good face on something
that really isn't resonating watch I
truly believe this country is about to
take off
because For the first time in a long
time we're bringing Pride back to cities
and towns all across America been left
behind I can honestly say I've never
been more optimistic about America's
future 76% of Americans saying America
is going in the wrong direction yeah you
know I think uh Biden's age is a huge
problem and it's not going to get any
better but I do think if things were
going well in the country and the world
a lot of Voters would say you know he's
really old and he's daughtering but
things are going pretty well it's okay
with me uh instead there was a there was
a quote in the time story a voter in
Pennsylvania who said the world is
falling apart under Biden and
domestically you look at the economy
people's standard of living has gone
down their purchasing power has gone
down you look at the the disaster on the
border spreading to Blue cities up north
you see crime in many places like here
in Washington and then you add to it a
huge war in Ukraine a new war in in
Israel and that guy who said the world
is falling apart under Biden that was a
reasonable way to look at things my
mother would say hel in a handbasket she
that was one of those sayings back then
the hel in a handbasket Mark um Stacey
Abrams polls at about three points
higher right now which is mind-blowing
to me but then Joe Biden but um Stacy
Abrams thinks kamla Harris is getting um
too much criticism watch do you think
she would be receiving these same
critiques if she was a white man no we
cannot ignore that misogyny and racism
remain very prevalent in our politics
there's also just the difference our
expectations are set for the traditional
white male vice
president Mark obviously I was talking
about comma PS three points higher uh
what is your thought on that do you
think it's racism that is really at the
heart of people's criticism of KLA
Harris I think KLA Harris is a an asset
that the Democrats should use more
absolutely people need to show that
she's there she's a steady leader and
and I think she can do the job um you
know when they talk about Biden's age
Biden and Trump are four years apart and
I'd be willing to bet that Donald Trump
given his health habits is going to die
a lot sooner than Joe Biden who's a very
health hoping Trump dies before Biden no
the the point is is that his age is not
an issue he's very healthy if but
there's only be two people running an
election is a choice and of the two
Donald Trump is in more danger why are
black voters moving to uh Trump well
you're talk you're talking about whether
it goes from 10 to 20% or something like
that 80% the vast majority of black
voters will support Joe Biden and I do
believe KLA Harris needs to get out
there and help support black votes I I I
mean I Mark I'm not trying to pick pick
on you honestly if I were in your
position I'd probably say the same thing
but this is the New York Times describes
this as an potentially epical shift away
from what the Democrats wanted to do on
progressivism and toward a more
multiethnic working class populism
that's in the New York Times I mean
that's not a conservative rag I do think
it's populism I think Donald Trump is
the classic populist that's why I want a
steady hand someone who respects
democracy someone who cares about
American values I mean 5.6% decline in
real median wages I mean is that real
wages are higher real wages are higher
than they've ever been real income
actually looked at with inflation it's
down that's not my number you see this
with Trump dominating here he has
multiple bases of support he has his
enthusiastic Maga supporters he has
people who just remember how nice life
was under his presidency he also has
people who are extremely worried that
Democrats are using law enforcement to
go after political opponents and try to
imprison political opponents people
worried about that kind of
authoritarianism this gives him three
really strong bases of support and you
see it in the numbers reflected that
younger voters are more likely to vote
for him black voters are more likely to
vote vron what do you think about that
axus is saying that Democrats are
quietly moving to succeed Biden they're
mentioning Nome Whitmer pritsker uh they
all have launched big um packs and
they're all kind of interesting you know
characters I'm not sure it would make a
big difference but they're looking at it
well first of all black voters are
moving away from Biden because they go
to the grocery store I think that's
pretty clear uh what's going and they go
to the gas station too uh you know as
far as any any replacement for Biden
it's in extremely hard to blast an
incumbent president president out of his
seat for the party and and if he did I I
I don't think there's any way in the
world Democrats could pass over vice
president Harris I she's the vice
president of the United States say let's
just say Okay I I I agree with you the
Democratic nomin okay I I I I agree with
you it's probably the way it's going to
go but if it wasn't how do they Leap
Frog against they're not going can't can
they no she's she's the vice president
of the United States she's the
Constitutional successor the woman of
are looking at 2028 Molly is there any
way to get to KLA Harris or get overla
Harris she's politically toxic but they
can't get over her now all right panel
great to see you all hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else